[Music]
you guys know the big news that we are
finally expecting we're so excited show
you the baby bump really quick i am 14
almost 15 weeks now and we're super
excited that you guys finally know the
big news i know in the past i've said
that as soon as we find out that we're
pregnant that we would let you guys know
you know after telling our friends and
family but with this pregnancy
especially after what we went through
with the previous pregnancy we were just
scared we were scared to be excited we
were scared to
to like announce it at all and we were
just waiting until we hit that second
trimester until you know they say like
once you hit i think it's 12 weeks or
something but we wanted to be super safe
and wait till the 14th week but they say
like after 12 weeks that your chances of
miscarriage drop to like two percent so
we're like okay that seems pretty safe
like we were really really nervous about
just being
excited for this one because we didn't
know what was gonna happen again and so
yeah so that's why we waited until now
now we get to be
excited and uh we kept saying that we
were being cautiously optimistic because
even at this point you you really don't
know what can happen like even in the
delivery like who knows what can happen
it's like it's scary it's really scary
um being at this point and not really
knowing what's ahead but as of right now
we're being cautiously optimistic
very excited very happy now we can tell
you guys the news so yeah and then like
because of the fact that i'm so far
along with this pregnancy you might be
like wait didn't you just announce that
you had a chemical pregnancy and yeah
and so i wanted to mention like the
reason why
we wanted to
talk about that is because we really
wanted to honor that experience and not
just kind of sweep it under the rug
and we really wanted to talk about it
and share what we went through so now
with this pregnancy
we were actually already pregnant when
we were filming that video but
clearly that wasn't like the appropriate
time to announce that we were already
pregnant i just
we just really wanted to at least like
voice that experience let it be known
let like honor it and then move on from
it yeah so that's why with this
pregnancy and then for the announcement
too like i don't know if you guys have
noticed but that's why i did rainbow
nails because they say after
after you have a pregnancy loss or not
even just pregnancy after you have a
loss that your next
pregnancy or your next baby is a rainbow
baby because there's a rainbow after the
storm so that's what this baby is
a little rainbow baby
okay i just took
pregnancy tests
i'm too scared to look down at it
but it's right here
it's it's about time the timer went off
[Music]
oh my gosh those lines are strong
oh my god
[Music]
case come here
so i was just telling the camera that we
bought this game of lotteria
and hola hola como estas
and so i want you to show them your
skills
okay
which was that one
uh
i kind of saw that one
it's okay which is one estrella
muy bien and
this one
what is that
and that and
i don't know this one
pregnant
impregnato
how do you say it
[Music]
i can't write z
yeah
[Music]
i'm pregnant
[Music]
oh
man really yeah
oh my god
i'm shaking that's so cool that's a
pregnant card
no
i had it specially ordered for us
what yeah i don't oh it's a fake yeah
it is i was like i don't recall ever
seen this one ever we've been trying for
so long i know like i i've got my i
i've don't want to get my hopes up man
oh my god this whole time too trying to
prep this i'm like go away you can't
follow me
you can follow me i was like go away
oh you did a good job then oh no man my
heart was pounding i'm like this is what
he must have felt like trying to propose
to me how about
this one
larosa
good job good job
how about
this one
we didn't do that one but uh
do you know what it is no yeah i don't
know
i would have never guessed that it's
kind of hard huh yeah do you know what
it is
no pregnant lady or something it's your
mom
oh
because i'm pregnant
[Music]
no wait
really yeah
congrats
yeah baby you're gonna be a big brother
nice
that was pretty good yeah yeah i mean i
thought we're going to play a lot of
lotteria which i didn't want to do
[Laughter]
[Music]
you guys are matching too i know
yeah i think about that over here i'm
wearing shorts earlier oh it's funny i
just changed into these because i
thought we were filming a video
where we needed to get dressed up for
and then it's this video
[Music]
this is gonna be the future nursery room
are you gonna put the
the desks and everything probably in our
room but it's going to be a while i'm
sure we have a couple months to figure
it all out yeah maybe even sell it are
you ready to have a a neighbor
yeah
because your room is right around right
on the other side of this wall yeah i
have a noisy neighborhood
to be who could be could be noisier
oh yeah you're gaming or the baby yeah i
put on my gaming because when i'm home
alone i scream to the top of my lungs oh
wow nice
time to do it it's pretty awesome any
names
boy girl
we've had a lot of conversations in the
past but we it was just like for play
like we didn't really take it seriously
yeah so now do you have any suggestions
no no you know i asked you a long long
oh yeah
tyrone you remember that yeah i remember
that i thought it was a good name it's a
good yeah it is strong it sounds like
someone that's really strong and like
stoic yeah that was cute though you were
like six years old and you're like i
have a brother i want his name to be
tyrone it's because i was playing this
uh game called lego batman yeah and
there's this guy named tyrone that's a
good name
cutie
what do you think now are there any
names that stand out to you now not
really it's okay i don't know we'll
figure it out all right so isaac asked
to see the pregnancy test
so usually
people don't like touching this because
p's on there but
let me tell you that
but you don't have to worry about that
because there's no p anywhere on the
anywhere actually because i dipped this
stick usually like people like pee on
the stick but i peed in a cup and then i
dipped it so there's no pee on this
stick on the outside of it
there's no pee i made sure
okay well i still feel a little
disgusting
yeah so you don't have to worry about
playing loteria
[Music]
okay good all right good ready yeah
let's go
let's help
[Music]
you